join us join us mightiest heroes not
today sir are you making your voice
deeper you know on April 27 summer
begins be looking he's trying to copy
man Avengers infinity war pg-13
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people
to see if we could become something more
so when they needed us we can fight the
battles they never could
the end is near Avengers infinity war
April 27th reddit run from it
the end is near we're gonna need some
help
how you been buck not bad for the end of
the world
[Music]
[Music]
David don't fight someone
we fight for all of them
Avengers infinity war when you said we
were going to open what conduct to the
rest of the world this is not what I
imagined
or if you imagine the Olympics maybe
even a Starbucks everywhere April 27th
tell me his name again Janice
we're gonna need some help let's go on
April 27
of ventures
once
and for all
I'm Peter dr. strange Oh using their
made-up names um I'm spider-man then
Avengers infinity war with a pg-13
sadness it could destroy life on Earth
we're gonna need some help from April 27
together is our only hope Avengers join
us
once and for all join us mightiest
heroes not today so are you making your
voice deeper no the gun is my voice so
cool Avengers infinity war DBT 13 on
April 27th where will you be when it all
ends
[Music]
Avengers infinity war with the pg-13